i mean no one don't bring it up yeah but
i also know this that like when you were
at the comedy cellar back in the day
yeah um and you were having your
children and the way you would do your
sets and have these kids
at the same time and the way you were
juggling all of that oh yeah i mean i
heard from comics from new york that
would talk about it that you were just
like always going up
but had this young family
and how did you juggle all that
you know it was it was a great uh break
from the chaos
but it was i don't know but you hadn't
made it had you made it at that point
but did you have kids before you made it
i did not i had one kid
and one on the way when i was taping
beyond the pill which was my first
comedy special oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um
but when my daughter my first daughter
was born
uh i was definitely uh there was no
guarantees you know that
i mean i think i knew i wasn't i could
support a child but i didn't
think that i didn't contemplate having
five or yeah you know
living in this nice house with you yeah
yeah but the reason i'm asking jim is
because i have a fear as a comic yeah
that like i'm 50 now
and i look at someone like you and you
have and al magical is another one with
kids and other comics and i and i think
to myself can i do it
am i because
i go
my job we we're children yeah right we
play and we [ __ ] around and we're free
in that way and it's like i'm just
afraid that i'm not going to be able to
do it as a dad as a dad
i think you underestimate yourself i
think that anyone because think about it
this there's a lot of funny people but
like to pull it together and do a set
and also
you know what
your podcast here is successful it's
like
you're playing and you're doing it and i
i i don't know i
feel like the whole parenting thing it's
it's look it's really hard but it's also
important for
evolving like look we know comedians
that you guys are in a relationship for
nine years we know people that like
can't pull off a month
so it's like
yeah you
definitely can do it yeah yeah i mean
and also it's like
the universe is kind of
like
you know like opportunities show you're
not going to be broke
you know what i mean yeah yeah it's like
there's people that did it
in much harder circumstances yeah yeah i
don't think that my fears of it can i
financially do it i think i i think i
worry
about because i have weird things where
it's like
you don't know this about me but i'm
very unhygienic
i smoke
right yeah i wake up at 4 pm yeah you
know i mean i have
i've never i haven't changed since i was
a young guy as a standard right you know
i mean and it's like i know i have to
change those things
if i want children but i really want
them well then you then have them it's
not that hard
it's and by the way it's like
this fear you don't have to grow the
baby you know what i mean
i do do you remember yeah i'm so glad
you're bringing this up why because now
you're telling everybody the truth that
the hold up has never been me that the
holdup has always been you
well dr gavigan crushing it
sorry jeff he's walking out
he's walking out
bobby get back here bobby bobby you're
right you're a door slam
you know what babe you're right the fear
has always been mean there is never the
right time to do it there isn't there's
never the right time yeah it's like oh
i'm 20. i don't have i don't even have a
serious job or oh um you know
she's about to do this or that or you're
doing it's like it's never the right
time
but and by the way the world's on fire
it's like it's not the right time but
it's it's it's like a piece of life that
is and i'm not saying everyone has to do
it yeah but i do think that like
it'll
you know like you'll meet the task
i think so i think it'll change me yeah
i don't have kids just so i'm not gonna
do it to change me i wouldn't do it to
change me it's kind of like a you know
an exercise thing this kid's gonna make
me lose weight
i had a kid so i get in shape yeah i
mean yeah
maybe you know
you know i think maybe
maybe
i think you named the baby jim
jim's a great that's a great name a
great name you know what i mean yeah is
jim a short for some other name you know
like
james james james
oh james lee yeah james lee are your
kids comics or no